Her low freak bitches.
You can whip those people up and get on
their frequency and then there's smart
people that can be manipulated.
They can be manipulated once they
attach themselves to an ideology.
Yup.
Like we were talking about like people
on the left that are avoiding all the
craziness about Hillary.
Like you had a quote that I really
liked that's on your Twitter.
You know that if like Hillary was a man
that had done the all the same things
that she like,
what is the quote?
What does it your exact,
I see,
remember I said a,
if Hillary was a male republican
with the exact same voting record,
all of her supporters would
hate her with a passion.
Yeah,
it's true.
And it's 100% sure.
100% true.
I mean it's not,
this is not controversial in any way,
shape or form.
Hillary is is,
you know,
I mean the stuff I was saying before,
but she's,
she's like courting the left.
She's courting people who are
supposed to be liberals and you'll go,
she's supported every
single war of my lifetime,
every single war.
Well now they know they can get past that.
She didn't support gay marriage up
until 2013 even their pet issues.
Yeah,
it's,
she's,
she's a weird one man.
She's a really,
really weird one.
That fucking Libya thing.
We came,
we saw,
he died
like,
that's okay.
Like are you kidding me?
What you remember when,
uh,
the fucking Vermont Guy Screamed?
I know I got to
Howard Dean and that one yell did men it,
that's it.
They saw it and they're like,
fuck this guy.
We,
we came,
we saw he died.
Ha ha ha.
Like that doesn't,
you don't think that
lady is fucking crazy.
You don't think that ladies fucking cars.
I mean,
you're down for her.
That's,
that is a completely an ideology thing.
You,
she's,
she's on your team.
You're going to,
you're going to go along with
it just like it's a religion.
Just like you're,
you're subscribing to
some predetermined thing.
It's,
it's,
it's just,
it's weird for me to see,
first of all,
it's weird that she wants to be president.
Like,
aren't you old?
Like you're an old lady.
How much energy do you have?
Got a ton of money.
You just had your first grandkid.
You've got like perspective,
like what it'll you're trying to do.
We're trying to make history as a woman.
Is that what it is?
I mean,
do you want to just like get back at
your husband for getting his Dick Sucked
and in 1991 or whatever the fucking was?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't even think it's that.
I think it's,
it's,
I mean,
who knows who I,
you know,
I'm not in their head,
but I think these people are like power
brokers that just want more and more of
it and it's a real,
it is probably a thrill unlike anything
we could imagine to have that much power
and they've,
they've tasted a little bit of that,
you know?
Yeah.
Just,
it seems to me that she's like so old
that she would just want to chill,
you know?
It just doesn't make any sense to me.
She's,
she's an old lady.
Like she doesn't have good health.
I think that was the other
thing that concerned with,
she had some health issues.
Right then she had like
concussions or something.
Yeah.
There was hit in the head.
I forget what it was,
but it was to beat the
fuck out of our imagine.
Turns out that bill just wailed on her
and she wants to keep it quiet until
fucking Kot.
He's been accused of violence.
Wow.
She has suffered from fainting spells
since at least 2005 and that year she
passed out presumably so,
or while giving a speech in 2012 she
passed out yet again and suffered a
concussion.
Holy Fuck.
Presumably sober is something
that if they ever have to say it,
it's just not good.
Yeah.
You got issues.
We're always presumably sober.
I'm not usually pursuing,
but all right.
You know,
but this idea that she fell asleep
and and hit her fucking head,
like when people fall and hit their head,
it's one of the worst things about getting
knocked out is not getting punched in
the head.
It's you falling down and getting
hit in the head with the earth.
Yeah.
Like their,
their heads bounce off the ground.
That's like a big issue in
street fights and stuff.
When you watch someone get sucker punched,
they will fall down in their head,
gets bounced off the curb.
And I think people who have like
epilepsy and things like that,
like that's the big fairly,
what happens is that that you end
up cracking your head on the ground.
It's not just the seizure seizures.
Um,
yeah,
there's,
there's something,
I don't know,
Hillary Clinton said recently,
and this would probably be one of the
tactics she tries to use against Trump,
but she said something along the gut.
She goes,
you know,
I just,
I,
I don't know if he's the type of guy we
would want having control of the nuclear
codes.
And it's just like an interesting thing
to look at what your like how crazy is
it that any one person has
control of those nuclear codes?
Like we're just counting
on one person to not snap,
to not kill the whole world to just,
yeah.
Hopefully you don't ever just like,
I've had enough.
I'm fucking,
yeah.
It's the,
the cigarettes and coffee thing
or the staples of the alcoholics,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of,
uh,
a people enjoy those cigarettes
and they enjoy those,
uh,
those coffees,
but you know,
in their eyes.
Yeah.
But then,
but in their eyes,
they feel like they've got the alcohol
part under wraps now because this stuff
just kind of keeps him going and
this stuff is not ruining their life.
Right.
Alotta alcohol,
she used cannabis the same way.
Um,
and uh,
that's not really accepted by Aa.
So I know a lot,
a lot of people who have kicked their
alcoholism by moving more towards
cannabis,
but again,
within the gay community
that they don't like that,
that's still considered a drug.
So,
but you can get it
addicted to anything,
you know,
whether it's set porn or dig
MACs or where we can get it,
uh,
psychologically addicted to anything.
But Jamie didn't,
the guy who created,
um,
alcoholics anonymous didn't have
positive experiences with LSD.
Okay.
That'd be funny.
That would be,
I feel like,
I feel like you did acid as the only
thing you're in that to take guys.
So I feel like,
I feel like,
uh,
that was something that
happened like maybe even after.
Okay.
Well,
I don't want to speak out of school.
Yeah,
my right.
I'll pull it up.
Yeah.
So what the fuck?
Well,
that's why the government
needs to live testing.
Oh,
on a lot of things.
So we know.
Scroll that up please.
Alcoholics anonymous foe a founder
believed LSD could cure alcoholism.
Wow.
You've seen so much research now in
psychedelics that clinics are opening up.
There's a clinic in,
in La for,
for Acadamin,
you know,
and you're seeing NDNA clinics opening up.
What?
Most of them do not realize
that the program's cofounder,
Bill Wilson credited the psychedelic
drugs LSD for alleviating his alcoholism
and believe the drug could be
used to treat others as well.
Holy Shit.
So those friends of bill,
they didn't get all the
information [inaudible] of bill.
If you're in the alcoholics anonymous,
right?
That's what they call themselves.
Like Ken's a bill.
It's like the code w but they
didn't get that experience.
It's kind of like the mushrooms,
like quitting cigarettes.
Yeah.
But do you think they tell them,
I never heard this before today.
How could you not tell these people?
Wilson first became,
uh,
began experimenting with
Lsd in Los Angeles at the
Veterans Administration back
in 1956.
But after taking his first hit of acid,
he realized that it was not the aspect
of terror that could help remedy
alcoholism,
but rather the insight one could attain
from stepping into a world of simulated
insanity.
And whoa.
Wilson believe that using the LSD could
help the alcoholic discover a power
greater than ourselves that in
turn could restore us to sanity.
However,
he was adamant that using acid to
combat the demons of alcoholism was not
something that he could,
that one could expect from a single dose.
He's like more research
is required and snacks.
Wow.
Hmm.
That's interesting,
man.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Psychedelics,
I think as we experiment within,
like medically,
I going to reveal some secrets.
This guy's,
this guy's a heavy duty tripper.
They're going further down.
He was tripping with Aldous Huxley.
Like this guy.
This isn't like one experience he had.
Interesting.
There's documentation that
indicates Wilson was involved
with many supervise LSD
trials,
including some with psychology,
a psychologist,
Betty Eisner and brave new world author,
Aldous Huxley,
which led them to believe that the
visions and insights given by l LSD could
create a large incentive,
at least in a considerable
number of people.
And so this was with like a leader,
and in fact,
they lift the left this
out of the AA pamphlet.
How do they,
how could they leave this out?
That's crazy.
Cause this seems like this had to play
a major part in this guy's ability to
kick alcohol
[inaudible].